ALWAYS.
SO ARKANSAS IS ONE OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE STATES IN THE
COUNTRY YOU KNOW THAT WE PULLED
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE WHAT
THEY THINK ABOUT THE VARIOUS
ISSUES, BUT LIKE A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVE STATES ARKANSAS IS
GOVERNED BY SOME VERY LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS.
SO JAKE BECKETT IS NOT ONE OF
THEM HE'S RUNNING FOR SENATE AND
THE PRIMARY AS A REPUBLICAN IN
THE STATE OF ARKANSAS AND IT
LOOKS LIKE NOT EVERYONE IS COOL
WITH THAT.
SO FOR HIS FIRST THING WAS
COMPLETELY WRONG ON THOUSANDS OF
BALLOTS.
THAT IS A PROBLEM FOR HIM
BECAUSE OTHER CANDIDATES HE'S
ALSO ON THE BALLOT.
ELECTION OFFICIALS TOLD US TODAY
THAT THEY FIX THE PROBLEM
STARTED IN THE ARKANSAS PRIMARY
THERE SUING I THOUGHT THIS WAS
INTERESTING SO WE ASKED HIM TO
COME ON EXPLAIN WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IT'S HARD NOT TO SEE MAYBE YOU
DON'T WANT TO SAY THIS OUT LOUD,
SEEMS LIKE SABOTAGE BY YOUR OWN
PARTY.
>> HERE IN ARKANSAS WE'VE A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS BUT NOT VERY MANY
CONSERVATIVE WARRIORS AND THAT'S
WHY M.
AT MY CORE I'M A WARRIOR.
WHEN THE ESTABLISHMENT LINES UP
AGAINST ME FOR FOUR, FIVE SUPER
PACKS RUNNING NONSTOP AND
PROBABLY ONE COMING UP IN THE
NEXT COMMERCIAL, BUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE AS EARLY VOTING
STARTED HERE ON MONDAY AND WE
DISCOVER THAT WE HAD OUTRAGED
VOTERS FOR MULTIPLE ARKANSAS
COUNTIES REACHING OUT TO ME WITH
SCREENSHOTS OF THE BALLOT BOXES
IN THE VOTING MACHINES MY NAME
WAS WRONG.
SO HE REACHED OUT TO THESE
COUNTIES WE EXPECTED THEY'D BE
SURPRISED.
MY GOSH THE BALLOTS ARE WRONG.
THEY HAVE PROVEN THEY ADMITTED
IT EFFORT FOR THREE WEEKS EARLY
VOTING STARTED THEY KNEW MY NAME
WAS GONNA BE WRONG AND SAID
NOTHING AND VIOLATION OF
ARKANSAS STATE LAW.
SO HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY THOUGHT I WAS PART OF THE
ALT-RIGHT.
THEY THOUGHT OUT SOME OF THESE
ESTABLISHMENT RHINOS WHO JUST
GONNA TAKE IT LYING DOWN SAY
OKAY ALL SHOCKS WILL GET THEM
NEXT TIME.
NO TUCKER I PUNCHED BACK.
I'M A NEW BUSINESS IS BUSINESS
IS BEING DONE IN A PART OF THE
NEW RIGHT WE FILED LAWSUITS WE
TOOK THE McCOURT TODAY IN
COURT THE JUDGE SAID THIS WHOLE
SITUATION WAS DEEPLY TROUBLING
IN ALL THE SUN TUCKER VOILA THEY
STARTED FIXING THESE VOTING
MACHINES AND THESE BALLADS
ORIGINALLY TOLD US AN ALLY RON
FIXABLE SO WE ALREADY GOT THEM
ON THE RUN TUCKER HERE IN
ARKANSAS.
40 FIX THEM IN ONE COUNTY WE
MADE SURE THAT THEY CAN VERIFY
AS REAGAN SAID TRUST AND VERIFY
WE SKIPPED THE TRUST WERE GOING
STRAIGHT TO VERIFY.
WE CAN MAKE SURE ON MONDAY THAT
ALL 75 ARKANSAS COUNTIES HAVE
THE CORRECT NAME ON THE BALLOT.
THAT'S JAKE BECKETT, NOT JACK.
I'M NOT GOING TO D.C. TO BE PART
OF THE ESTABLISHMENT REGIME.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE WARRIOR, FIVE
FOR THE CITIZENS OF ARKANSAS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT
SHOULD NOT BE A ISSUE.
IF YOU HAVE THE COURAGE TO PUT
YOUR NAME ON THE BALLOT TO RUN
IF YOU LOVE YOUR COUNTRY ENOUGH
TO RUN FOR OFFICE AND SERVE OUR
COUNTRY, IF YOU'RE REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT, GREEN PARTY, WHO CARES
IN A CARE WHAT OFFICER SEATING.
YOU DESERVE TO HAVE THE VOTERS
BE FULLY INFORMED, BE FULLY
ENFRANCHISED AND KNOW WHO
THEY'RE VOTING FOR.
SO WHEN I WIN THIS RACE AND THIS
PRIMARY GO TO THE U.S. SENATE
WOULD TURN THE GUNS OF THE
ARKANSAS A RHINO, FIX THIS ONCE
AND FOR ALL, MAKE SURE THAT
ARKANSAS SECURE ELECTIONS.
>> Tucker: AND POLITICIANS WHO
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
ARKANSAS.
THEY DON'T REPRESENT YOUR
AVERAGE RECORD ARKANSAS
REPUBLICAN I'M SORRY.